Our last question was basically our next steps.
I mean we've learned a lot of service side technology, introduction of programming-type things,
Where do our students go from here and what would you recommend they learn next?
Sure. So I would start getting good at two main technologies.
One is JavaScript, which is a completely separate programing language
from anything we've talked about in this class
in that it runs in the browser, and so you can make your web page do fancier things.
The other is CSS--I've had some CSS in the homeworks and in the lectures
but I've never quizzed you guys on it because we don't know how to even grade the CSS yet.
And this is how you described what your pages look like--
colors and font sizes and boxes and layouts and all that sort of stuff.
Basically everything you've learned in the class, you can make
a pretty substantial website with everything you've learned in this class up until this point.
And JavaScript and CSS, you can make your website look more professional,
look more like a website, but functionally, you can do all the major things.
JavaScript and CSS--if you learned those, you'll have a lot of tools in your toolbox.
Okay. Great! I think that's all the questions we had.
Unit 6 and homework 6 has just been posted--anything you want to say
about that or about week 7 and the final?
Unit 6 is caching, basically 101 ways to use memcache.
That should be a fun one--the homework should be pretty straightforward I think..
And in Unit 7, no more quizzes in Unit 7.
It's basically we're just going to talk about a lot of the real world stuff we did with growing Reddit,
and we'll talk to some of the Udacity engineers about how they app engine in production.
Then the final is basically going to be building another
website similar to your blog but this time all at once and we''ll talk all about that in Unit 7.
One last question I just remembered was how to prep for the final, and I would recommend
personally that you just make sure you have all the homework done and you understand it.
If you have those things done, I would say the final really shouldn't be bad.
Yeah! If you've done the homeworks, the final shouldn't be any problem.
In fact, after I wrote the final code, about two-thirds of that code is from homeworks.
The user a registration stuff, the caching stuff-it's all--you'll find yourself when you're writing
any web application a lot about that--a lot of that code will get reused over and over again.
That why we taught it.
If you can do the homework, you shouldn't have any problem with the finals.
Okay. Great! Well, see you in class. >>Right. Bye guys!